[Música]
y sí no
y
qué es
sin esta palabra ocasional
eso implica más en el campo de la salida
del campo de realimentación de su
significado real que es la acción de
coordinar la suma de dos o más partes o
causas que siempre sea mayor
una
en buenas palabras significa
tiene una grabación
la disciplina de resolver problemas
todos mis conocimientos y experiencia
[Música]
esa determina el sol viendo el problema
y está sacando nación
es muy interesante establemente guardián
a verlo
algunos días
en la trilogía de los anillos
los metales
y no totalmente herencia de técnicos y
vamos
y dijo que sí
d
arriba de la película película tan
interesante
en su mismo
todos ellos son un mejor escenario
problemas
2 en su mundo el presionarlo
pero esta película al jugar más grande
combinatoria mente cada equipo
el señor que vemos con él
y es que es muy inteligente para
analizar el plan de andar que va a
utilizar donde el el mismo
y el sr
en primer lugar
y ahora
pero realmente es más grande pero igual
para ser
no me entiende
en el equipo
una realidad decimos a mí
verdad
[Música]
actualmente
todas las visiones de la visita pública
[Música]
en
no existe por la mención mundial de la
salud
en todas las horas
se dedican a proyectar la salud
as
y esto en verdad es el verdadero enemigo
media
cuál es el problema
[Música]
quiero bien así es agua para
restaurantes de este nuevo gobierno
[Música]
los servicios de salud pública
quién es responsable
simplemente todo antes sin ninguna
responsabilidad
y vamos a empezar
el paciente puede decir
en 1
y él
[Música]
es atractiva
en una cuenta simplemente
vamos a pasarnos sobre el oasis
[Música]
amor
también
con un espacio de videollamada
consultorio el modelo soy una autoridad
lo mismo porque es algo
y si no te interesa
simplemente
nos basamos
[Música]
como nosotros
y si quiero
tú eres el que decide consumir como
[Música]
en términos de consumo
y si nos pasamos al cuarto participante
que serían los servicios de salud
pública
en él
bingo
así
tales
un diálogo
agregamos mi ánimo de regalos y 4
de activación
o
[Música]
no tienes que gastar
ellas
como contable
vamos a pasar a diferentes conocidas
ahora es de los anteriores
en llegar
vamos a poner
vamos a llegar
y en los canales de ilusión educativa
y las soluciones no vamos a buscar
tienes en forma
haciendo un pequeño paréntesis
no
verás cuando hagamos una acción
importante
cuántos de nosotros alumnos de nuestro
com
un catedrático
quisiera entre comillas de bienes obras
acerca de las sombras de sus vidas
cómo
de hecho
y vamos desde
continua
vamos a ver
pero luego son la cama
y no se dan cuenta como dice el punto d
la imagen es un bar donde alguno
y que si no en su totalidad
las oraciones
y vean
tenemos viviendo el alumno
no tengo los libros necesarios
[Música]
básicamente podría ser un carrera
diga
muchísimo lugar al investigar
esta es una educativa
ahí tienes aulas
y en los mismos
y luego
informes
lo mismo
y el enfoque de decir las soluciones
hoy en día demasiado
tengo poner dos impresionantes
muchísimos de nosotros nos encontramos
y
uno de ellos son los productos milagros
los pimientos las pastillas
nos quedamos hasta bien
o
y las pastillitas
bien
competidores
yo lo el ojo
consecuencias publican lo realmente
riesgo
[Música]
en demasiado
y no viendo en comisión
tienen al mejor
bien
[Música]
a quien no le gustaría
tiene un poder una estrategia
increíble nuestra desventaja como
profesionales de la salud es que tenemos
es muy buenos amigos
[Música]
para vender la salud
no
d
no se va a inventar
estamos estamos
d
y esa bendita
nosotros
desde salud
en nuestro grupo
vivo
y después
yo soy la cura porque para la unidad
medicina
[Música]
y se nos olvida
la salud es nuestro fin
un equipo multidisciplinario no es nada
más
un íntimo parís tener la conciencia que
yo con más bueno que sea en miami con
individual profesional
necesito ambulatoriamente
porque somos
y eso te digo hay una pregunta alguien
de
me encanta platicando
demasiado
de eso
quiero
los poquitos
[Música]
porque al haber solo
me dio resultados
bien
estamos como
pero tengo no sé
[Música]
estoy buscando
porque entiendo que uno
un ace
siempre el mismo
yo
[Música]
dónde
la convención del dimensionado igual
está muy por debajo del resultado que
puede tener
ya está bien atendido
sólo se traduce en una indicación
su estación indicación de humo sin dar
ningún paso
es como viviendo nuestro público
con indicación ante un alumno
únicamente
de editar de su día de razón
el timbre ha hecho de decidir pero que
tiene saciedad en tu vida
es ayudar
de ti
necesitas un agente que necesitas
yo
y esta es una invitación a sí misma
d
[Música]
a tiempo
lo que tú digas es un místico
eres un orientador de urabá
ah
la verdad
y finalmente es una invitación para ti
maestro
nunca
bueno
es una visa de servir un personal que
tomó la decisión
y ellos
y hoy en día
paso
en cádiz
[Aplausos]